in this video I'm going to talk about
crosstalk between signaling pathways so
the signaling pathways in a cell doesn't
work alone so there are a lot of overlap
between signaling pathways and how these
overlaps are happening so it appears
that the downstream signaling molecules
such as second messenger used by both
the signaling pathways are sim so this
enables the cell to transduce signal in
a more faster manner than using distinct
signaling molecules so for instance here
we have gpcr mediated signaling pathway
going on and here we have our receptor
tyrosine kinase mediated pathway going
on and here in the GPC our pathway upon
linman binding in the membrane the
receptor associated g protein undergoes
a conformational change so that the gdp
is exchanged with GTP and thus GTP is
actually activating the phospholipase C
gamma phospholipase C beta I'm sorry for
sloppy C beta and this phospholipase C
beta Cleaves pip to that is phosphatidyl
inositol bisphosphate and cleaves pip 2
into IP 3 and D AG and IP 3 d AG both
are the second messengers IP threes
inositol triphosphate and d AG is diacyl
glycerol from the other side the
receptor tyrosine kinase upon ligand
binding receptor tyrosine kinase get
phosphorylated on its cytoplasmic domain
and it activates enough plc beta the
phospholipids C gamma I'm sorry the
phospholipase C gamma so when
phospholipase C gamma is activated
phospholipase C gamma also Cleaves pip 2
and generates IP 3 and d AG so both the
signaling pathway ultimately generates
the IP 3 and d AG so i p3 is the
molecule and d AG is the molecule on
which these two signaling pathway are
overlapping with each other so i p3
would go and do and bind to the
calcium channels on the ER on
endoplasmic reticulum and it will
release the calcium ion onto the
cytoplasm and this calcium ion will
activate two protein kinase c and
protein kinase C being a kinase it will
its target are many downstream signaling
molecules and it phosphorylates those
proteins thus we can see how these two
distinct signaling pathways mediated by
two distinct distinct receptors are
cross talking with each other and these
two signaling pathways between these two
signaling pathways there are there is a
degree of overlap I hope you liked it
please subscribe and like